- You have the most like
comfortable relationship ever.
I love it.
How did y'all meet?
- Dave and I, well, we met at Mardi Gras,
which is its own story.
You can Google it.
- Beads were involved possibly.
- Yes.
But we realized, you know, we
met through a mutual friend,
my friend Jules, who was
in the cover band with me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And we realized after we had
been dating for quite a while
we were kind of trying
to do the math on like,
when you're introduced
from a mutual friend,
you're kinda like, we
must have met before.
- Both been at the same
place or something.
- Right.
Like this friend of mine
used to have an annual
Halloween party every year.
It was like a big thing
and everyone she knew
came to it every year.
So, that was us kind of sitting and going.
Like, I was like, "Well,
you must have been at
Jules's Halloween party."
And he's like, "Definitely,
I went many times."
So now we start playing like
Halloween costume roulette
of like, I'm like, do you
remember when we were,
yeah, synchronized swimmers?
No.
I'm like, how about when
we were California raisins.
Nobody knew what we were.
And everybody spent the night
putting out different guesses
for what the costume was.
But so, to show people, to demonstrate.
We spent the whole night
gathering in little groups
and singing "I Heard it
Through the Grapevine"
and he was like, "Yes, I do remember that!
I was at the party dressed as,
me and my friend were Mario and Luigi."
And I was like, "I don't
remember that at all.
You don't exist to me."
- You were not memorable.
- So then we go back, I
find on an old computer,
a video from that night
of me and three of my friends singing
"I Heard it Through the Grapevine."
And it's tight on us.
Who is in the back corner of the video
but Mario and Luigi.
The cutest Mario I've ever seen seen.
- Isn't that weird?
That's a movie.